ранок примусив до
стріляли на донбасі на вухо і по
про режим їжі на продажі де активи
і тревал і безперервно 19-го ден
заданому по центру ато бойовики на марсі
штаму вата па зайти українців ризиково
службам тиф та вікна слідок за два дні
заглянув і семеро українських воїнів та
більше десятка пора на ній врятувати
лігачова по і все зафіксувала на
2000 порушено режиму тисячі за дубу при
чому до буму сторони ми abc ронінів tf
каунда головна причина це ваще
збувається в гіпсі грошей і прагне вже
сильно близькі з турину надводна c
виробляє допустимих на пружині йти на
пружини а завжди escalade до бойових
дитинка no me я цей спосіб змінити та
розвести позиції в цих районах на
дистанцію таке можна вицвілі то
будете хвиля візит кореня з наших
глядачів читка видно вважав би дві сторони
порушити миски думала нас їсти за 100
сови і чого шафа зброї не близько
видалення розмежування там дивани травня
буде анди контактами ось з його фоміч
шансів у кльовий замову дають і ви
не моя скеля ти називаєте росію і
проросійських бойовиків
потрібно smooth це маску б кімнати
мінської духовності та passat це і є
застиг промовивши еньші альтернативи ви
вирішення проблеми повз і на полі of
president Петра порошенка сумую тисяч
з канцлер ангела Меркель
у берліні сьогоднішній день по три дні
об'єктами або жартування геї
вирішу чиї ідеї для того, щоб за мати
валака російську сторону ніби за
столом переговорів замотувати та
implement у лота у повному про size
мінські домовленості у польську черву їх
без піковий компонент зроблено в
швидко навіть цивільного
населення на донбасі то я абсолютно
не зрозуміло
коли я хочу імплементація мінських
завгодний вигляд булатом ці
порошенка зникають дати сидожі
відомого за суму заощаджень china
послання санте на витяг
на росію can снорків р-н дуже ви
знаєте режим тисяч заснований на ідеї ти
про свою санкцію про канаву місто на
тому є мер як продовжу і по кудись
знайди
на норманський формат за долю русі та
ми віримо ще нормандський формат і в
подальшому правильному шлях по про
потужний опер вище в рамках всього
процесу можна досі
світу в Україні стабільної політичної
ситуації the third реальні цілі солодощі
українці ж спілкуватися і шлях душі
крупи тканина теж зус 342 crane розуму
жилось al cuore ним дорожньою картою
долин таті та мінських духовних state про
її норманської четвірка думалося рахунку
рику листопаді тим часом у bsm викурити
детальний вид порушення перемир'я на
основі запасу комерс пастори женева а
де йти